are you rolling rolling yo
bootleghett.com we're on the bus i'm a
little drunk shout out to rhetoric fed
me a lot of uh tequila there's weed we
have some weed that i just smelled
smells lovely my dude logic is in the
building i'm here technically it's not a
building it's a bus but anyway yeah you
know [__] on youtube like
[__] idiot [__] idiot on a bus hey
so logic man um
let's talk about when the [__] your
first album's gonna come out okay
what's going on with that or how about
we do this
you told me something got scrapped off
camera can we can we confirm this on
video i don't know i don't necessarily
know if it's a hundred percent but i was
thinking about the whole why you wait ep
and i'm thinking like
every day my [__] mentions on twitter
they're just like we want the album we
want the album right and i'm kind of
thinking about just giving some [__]
from the album and just starting that
process you know what i mean from music
videos crapping the ep you've already
put out four records uh lately yeah yeah
i mean we put out four records and
there's more records coming too so it's
like oh this [__] you was gonna get on
the ep you're gonna have anyway like you
already got all this [__] you know so
scrap vp gets like yeah i think we're
just gonna go straight for the album
because that's what the people want you
know what i mean every day every day you
know wednesday i was yeah we want to
single we want this we want that and
honestly i think you know i love my fans
and i'm just gonna give them what they
want so so no ep uh while you wait i
love how he's like gonna put this in the
title it's like 100 percent
ip logic scraps ep will be the headline
on rap radar
but the the the the tour is still the
you a tour still why you wait tour
because all this is while you wait
however music we're doing these
interviews it's it's to let the you know
give the fans something um we're talking
man like
the rosenberg interview you did was
great yeah sway interview you did was
great um
what i guess like now that you're kind
of like i mean
you've dabbled in your personal life
through your music a little bit but you
really haven't um
spoken on it
outside of that now that you're kind of
like
like what made you kind of want to put
kind of that transition the personal
stuff out there man
i think it's just because it's who i am
you know for a long time when i first
came out it was like i'm gonna hit y'all
with some crazy flow and some like fab
type punch lines like really impressive
[__] in my raps like that's kind of what
i was about and then as i got older you
know and every day i still am and just
mature and i'm like
this [__] is cool and this like stunt
fun hip hop braggadocio stuff it's cool
it's fun you know there's some of that
on the album for sure but like you know
i wanted to honestly just tell my story
because i noticed that when fans go you
know uh this is my favorite song like on
any of the mixtapes it's always the ones
that are like the really raw
very honest heartfelt records so i'm
like man [__] it i'm just gonna do that
i'm gonna make it the whole album and
i'm gonna really tell tell everybody
what they haven't heard you know in
detail so the album is pretty much what
your core fans love about you is gonna
be the album yeah
yes so that's
so everybody out there you have
something yo how many people hated you
when you did the song with trinidad
james was kidding on that song kidding
was on that song too shout out to him
that was that was that was cool that he
did that um it was cool that trinidad
did that trinidad was super popping at
that time too
no more
oh no that's fine
not him sorry that's my homie
that's good he just put out the death
champ video great video yeah he's like
great video he's he's the nicest dude
and he's a very nice guy
and he really is an incredible sneaker
head his
sneaker tv show on youtube is incredible
but yeah man nah he's a good dude that
was yeah no that was fun uh i think my
fans understood it you know it was just
some [__] that was tight something fun i
guess we're on the double xl cover on
the double cell to cover together i met
him there he was a very nice person and
i just vibed with him and he was on some
swag [__] and it fit the record so you
know we did that together and then uh i
have a homie named kb who's a producer
um he knew kia ink and all them and
linked us through that and kid inc was
you know kind enough to hop on the
record he was [__] with it and yeah
it was dope um being as you're a double
xl alumni yeah which is weird last year
yeah um
who do you think
who would you have put on the cover that
didn't make it now i don't want you to
tell me you'd replace but who would you
no of course um casey veggies that's my
number one that's what i've been saying
because like i feel like he deserves to
be yeah i should have been online he
should have been on the last year he
should have been on the year before he's
been popping for a long time in case
he's been out there everybody knows him
just like dom i'm just like i was very
disappointed by the i mean i i love ty
dolla sign he's the only west coast
representation on the cover but he's not
a rapper yeah it's more r b it's kind of
like it's it's hybrid it's the
melodic-ness there um but i get it but i
understand just like the source in their
five mics like when when double xl sits
down vanessa and all them they they go
crazy like they're at each other's knees
no i talked about this i interviewed her
and she gave me a lot of the um yeah i
just feel like it's a little useful i
mean you live in l.a so i guess you
really see i see it you see the
i mean impact that a guy like i am sue
or veggies has of course even problems
all over the radio so it's like a whole
bunch of yeah dog but you know with that
scheme like
yeah see this guy's yeah he lives
but
you know with all that it's it's just is
what it is because you know the dopest
of the dopest [__] are going to
prevail with or with that no matter what
yeah 100 you know what i mean but yeah
double xl is dope but when i honestly
like at the end of the day when i think
about double xl and when that cover
comes out i look for the spitters that's
what i look for i look for the you know
the chances the vic manchester jared
benjamin you know what i'm saying yeah
[__] isaiah yeah john connor i look
for john connor is someone who could
have made it five years ago i know
real talk i remember being uh at south
by southwest for my first time this last
time i was there two 2010 and john
connor was walking around with his whole
team and they had like the john connor
shirts and like these big ass signs and
[__] so it was really cool he's a very
nice dude super super nice people